[Music]
i don't think nico should be the in-game
leader for face claim and the a site's
open only flaming can stop the
guardian what are they up to why are
they just walking backwards into library
i can't even explain that one i can't
even give the benefit of the doubt i
don't know
what the purpose of walking backwards
there was and then we've been struggling
a lot because
i didn't know how to really do it or
let's say i didn't know how to handle it
and nico should be landing that shot
instead oscar
destroys him and mousesports will get a
10-5 lead
you need niko to be unleashed you need
him to free him from all
responsibilities within the game and
just let niko be nico
lines up the kill through smoke nico
sees the man in the raptors tapping for
it gets the spray down glaive with a
slight health advantage
but nico's going to fall back taking
further damage
faking the plant once and coming back
out for the kill oh my god
he's walking up the left this is gonna
be hard to read glade knows what's about
to happen
oh but he can't stop it see him
somewhere
that's the only thing is the element of
surprise maybe get one quick kill that's
gonna be the head shot yeah he's being
just into that corner push all the time
he's gonna get one more
oh it's happening away and then when you
don't do that and you actually just get
completely
wrecked in the following round that's
kind of hard to deal with grenade
and device don't make it up for all of a
second nico with him nice
drops down into the vents nico knows
this look at this angle he peeks
oh my goodness nico with the goal
to go for the fight
after bombing out of the london facet
major in april 2018
faze clan and nico were in trouble they
were a super team
who despite a few flashes of brilliance
never quite found consistent success
the fact that magisk has that position
in boiler so he knows no one's top mid
that one nade that nico just threw it's
not gonna fool anyone no one's even in
the bomb site to see it
oh faze about to enter a world of hurt
yeah this might be the worst call they
could make right now they can't really
know what 10 seconds in device
they're the rest of the teams are
following up the bomb is committing to
it as well
and they're out of time they cannot win
the round any longer and megas come
behind as well
once again they're getting locked in and
time is out and again
going down after the clock is run out
here an absolute disaster 15 to 11.
for nico it was especially painful
because when he signed with faze in
early 2017
people had huge expectations for him
expectations rooted in his incredible
talent
he had skills that made people call him
a prodigy that made them call him
godlike kerrigan dies in the last rounds
so too to see in this one
oh the auto sniper that gives the flick
with their best chance except the nico's
still
in the back of the site and he's got
accuracy he's gone oh my god
get off the but despite nico's insane
level of individual play
the phase clan experiment is largely
considered a failure
at least as far as super teams go i
think nico is a
a great player i think he's doing a
decent job as an in-game leader but if
you want a team that is
going to be able to compete with the
very best in the world you need niko to
be unleashed you need him to free him
from all responsibilities within the
game and just let niko be niko
find someone who can lead this team give
yanko a little more time and that's a
better recipe for face than what we're
seeing right now
following the 2018 london major faze
clan bombed out of esl one new york and
then continued to show mixed results
they won epicenter but then fell
short at im chicago and esl pro league
season 8.
but even when faze clan as a team
disappointed nico was still
popping off reminding us why he'd been
revered for so long
but here's rain two more kills and nico
to add in and suddenly
how is this turned around device to
debris at low hp it's a one on two
look at how low they are with the deagle
one shot on either player could pretty
much seal it
nico close said it he sees it gonna get
the kill does he realize he doesn't know
oh
god nico a beautiful triple
so faze trying to do what they can to
compensate aren't having any longer down
to two not a kill yet going
their way olaf tries to flash himself
back into the equation on quad but
there's three
players players down below and edward
gets positioned first on the og
electronic will close it out
killed by somebody trying to do that
swag has gone down in the meantime
out of it oh
he picked up he just clicked away with
the ak-47
that will strike fear right into your
heart warning we've seen him braille
some head shots and he does it again a
spitting image
as to the previous hit and the spray
down continues a complete and utter hold
for magisk and as his gun goes dry
it's perfect zip x has arrived takes the
closer corner onto the car
frag grenade supports olaf's gone and
nico follows suit
people blamed faze clan's subpar results
on all kinds of things from a lack of
team cohesion to nico's
underwhelming time as a team's igl see
before he joined faze clan
nico often shouldered the responsibility
of being his team's in-game leader
going all the way back to his early days
as a pro on mouse sports nico took over
as igl from god b
becoming the team's guiding force win or
lose
i'm in game leader but i'm not like we
do this you have to do that
you have to do that time like we play
standard you just
do what you think it's like best to win
the round
and like my role is just to make some
pressure on the other side try to get
some entry crack
to lurk if i can just to make pressure
that they're using all the utilities
there to throwing smokes grenades
everything and then we just group up and
do something together
but on faze clan nico wasn't the igo at
least not at first
initially kerrigan one of the best igls
to ever do it was charged with leading
the super team
and with kerrigan in charge nico was
free to focus on what he was
best at deleting players from the server
nico's got them sitting in the right to
the track to the pistol
if they lose like this it would be a
disaster the burden of leadership was no
longer his to carry something that nico
struggled with for a long time as he
told doubletap in a 2017 interview
struggles really came after we kicked
cop b
when i had to take over in-game leading
stuff and then we've been struggling a
lot because
i didn't know how to really do it or
let's say i didn't know how to handle it
so there was a lot of pressure on us and
even on myself i was like i was putting
my mouth
a lot of pressure on myself because i
just couldn't do it but as the losses
continued to pile up in the back half of
2018
nico changed his mind and very publicly
took over from kerrigan
the push and pull between nico the igl
and nico the superstar fragger has
existed for most of his career
at its best it was a combination that
provided some truly awe-inspiring
moments of counter-strike
now that guardian's jump spotted a body
he's gonna try to pry for the pick and
he'll get it
sergey shall not clutch this round
oh and then they replace guardian with
kerrigan he gets up with the m4 has to
let a player pass does drop the bomb and
guardian
playing along by just rounding these
corners
x7 he'd love to get this second kill and
try to make the most of a situation but
it's all cut
short launders supreme with the mid
control and zipex going for the
information here from catwalk if he sees
that there's nobody there it's just
gonna be a cone of gunfire over towards
long they can even spam through smoke
with guardian with a
gorgeous pick and a fried grenade that
could do so much damage yes glaive even
picking up a frag from it
but faze have doubled down now and he's
going to go for the jump shot which
costs him niko with a head over the top
of the smoke
establishes this 4v2 but at its worst
when nico was at odds with himself
faze clan was a confusing mess that
struggled to get energy killed
he planted down putting mousesports
really up against it of course the last
round of the half
he better believe they're going for it
that molly is horrible
yeah just goes in mid-air does nothing
at all for fade
and our guardian is gonna have to turn
his attention to tunnels with a
flashbang
prestige the peak and it will be
stunning
and nico should be landing that shot
instead oscar
destroys him and mousesports will get a
10-5
lead and the a side's open only flame he
can stop the
guardian what are they up to why are
they just walking backwards into library
i can't even explain that one i can't
even give the benefit of the doubt i
don't know
what the purpose of walking backwards
there was under niko's leadership
things got worse a few blast pro series
wins notwithstanding
2019 was not a good year for nico or
faze clan
on top of that a series of roster
changes kept breaking up the team
cohesion and momentum that nico and faze
so
desperately needed sure faze still had
the potential to beat
anybody in the world on a good day but
they were no longer the revered
super team they once were as 2020 rolled
around in a global pandemic forced
competitive counter-strike online
frustrations mounted as nico and faze
continued to underperform
fans were frustrated that one of the
best players in the world
couldn't consistently shine the way they
knew he could
but despite everything that was going on
nico continued to have moments of pure
brilliance on the server that moves
towards the a site
tech nine still amazing
respect to hunter that will enable the
plan nico though is not missing much
vision or otherwise he's posted up to
catch next sir and he does hit
it god he's looking deadly hunter's in
trouble
everything on for the ace boys for the
ace broken will take it but my god
you see why they give him the upon dust
too as summer turned to fall
and the weather cooled rumors began to
spread that nico was leaving phase for
g2
and fans wondered if g2 could afford
what had to be one of the most expensive
superstars to ever play the game
and for nico would a change of scenery
even make a difference
well we didn't have to wait long to find
out yeah i think they're hoping to see
him somewhere
that's the only thing is the element of
surprise maybe get one quick kill that's
gonna be the head shot yeah he's being
just into that corner push all the time
he's gonna get one more
oh tapping away what a genius one versus
three from nico yet again
you don't do that and you actually just
get completely wrecked in the following
round
that's kind of hard to deal with grenade
and device
don't make it up for all of a second
nico with a nice ace
drops down into the vents nico knows
this look at this angle he peeks
oh my goodness but it seems like g2 has
finally unlocked one of the deadliest
aimers csgo has ever seen
and is letting him do what he does best
click on heads
and rack up frags gonna be sprinting out
long a
nico he's got himself three kills